hey youtubers is charlie thank you
everyone that submitted questions for
this week's Korra Q&A I know it was only
a clip show but I still wanted to do my
regular videos no matter what and thank
you everyone for all the great
suggestions for other anime series to
check out as we start to wind down on
Avatar depending on what they announced
in terms of comics and stuff I'll
Whittle it down to a couple new series
and you guys could vote on which one you
want to talk about the most whenever I'm
picking stuff to do videos for I always
try to find stuff that people want to
talk about there's a tons of interesting
stuff but there's always going to be a
couple things that people just enjoy
talking about more speaking of which on
to questions so let's go careful for
spoilers from the episode if you haven't
seen it yet question number one anique
as will Korra strip kuvira verb ending a
la Susan's comet avatar aang I'm
actually expending it to be more about
forgiveness I don't think that she's
gonna take anything away from her I
think it'll be like hugs Pai sho and
forgiveness the only reason I don't
think that there's gonna be some big
battle between Korra and kuvira at the
end is that break said that it's not
going to be something that depends on
her ability to bend like her bending
ability it's not gonna be a contest I
feel like if they were gonna do a
sozin's comet type thing they would have
done it during the book 3 finale with
sahir like she would have taken his
bending away then if she hadn't gotten
TKO'd so bad question number two wing
zero asked do you think that ma co would
stay with wu after book four ends is the
earth king's head of security i think
there are a couple possibilities with ma
co he could either try to rejoin the
police force in Republic City which I
don't think that linds gonna let him or
he would go with whoo if he does end up
going with mu I think he'd be more of an
advisor less of a security chief
somewhere between what Lin bei Fong does
for president Raiko and a personal
advisor question number three space
gypsy s do you think when Legend of
Korra goes over to the comics we'll get
to see some fun exciting side
backstories I'm curious to see how
quorum at naga being basically locked up
most of her life in that avatar training
camp they haven't technically announced
any core comics although I'm expecting
them to do it at some point at least in
a small way and I think that yeah that's
totally possible when Bryke said that
they were finishing up legend of korra
book 4 you know the final TV episodes
they did say there would be some small
things coming along the way they didn't
say what those were they could be
digital shorts they could be comics they
made it sound like it was a
video type thing though it's most likely
that they would just do a QA where they
answer those questions and then a fan
animates them someone does some fanart
that fills in the gaps for the most part
unless it's going to spoil some future
episode which won't be the case they're
usually open to answering questions like
that they're really good about it also
don't forget that they will continue to
go to comic-con so you can actually meet
them if they're there promoting
something else and ask them questions
like that question number 4 avatar aang
gasps do you think that Toph melon Lord
will fight kuvira in the next episode
and if she does do you think that she'll
use sue and Sue's children as leverage
to keep top from destroying her I'm
really hoping that tough has some sort
of confrontation with kuvira I don't
think it's going to go down the way we
think it is I do think the top is going
to try and stop her from chopping down
the banyan tree or continuing to chop it
down the other option is the top goes
straight first Sue and her family and
tries to rescue them it doesn't deal
with QPR inside the swamp question
number 5 jackass any theories on the
moving spirit vines in the preview of
the next episode so yeah you're talking
about this right here it looks like the
spirit vines are going to retaliate for
what kuvira's doing in the swamp it's
implied that the root system for
everything is connected the clip makes
it seem like they're attacking but
really I think it's a defensive move so
far we haven't really seen the spirit
world react to what kuvira's doing
question number 6 index ass will you
ever review any Japanese anime like
Tokyo ghoul terraformer or Naruto I'm
totally open to any kind of anime I'll
make my decision as we slowly wind down
on Avatar though so don't worry plenty
of time to suggest things question
number 7 super loaded girl asks since we
got no update on kuvira in this episode
what do you think she was doing during
the events of the episode do you think
she's still harvesting spirit vines or
she doing something else I think she's
just continuing to chop down the swamp
tree by tree it doesn't seem like a
whole lot of time passed even though we
visited all the people on team Korra it
only seems like it was half a day at
most there's no way that Kubiak could
chop down the entire Banyan Grove tree
in that time I don't know which way
bright went with it but I'm really
hoping that bright did not let kuvira
chop down the entire Banyan Grove tree
that would be as bad as watching top
died and just be so depressing question
number 8 Caitlyn ass do you think that
the fight between Corran kuvira
South foo with the last physical battle
that they'll have this season or will
they have a similar core versus a year
battle so they won't be like another
version of four verses here at the end
but I do think there will be another
physical fight before that happens
there's five episodes left right now
including episode nine so there's still
gonna be a lot of punching I just I feel
like the last time Cora faces kuvira
it's not going to be like a punch you in
your face type fight we haven't seen
kuvira touched the Banyan Grove tree and
you know see through the root system
like Toph talk Korra to I think it's
possible that Cora could allow cougar to
do that or help her do that and that
will cause kuvira to settle down and
when I say settle down I mean tell her
army to go home and chill out question
number 9 ma co asked hey Charlie do you
think they would actually kill off Korra
in the finale in terms of resetting the
Avatar cycle I did see a rumor about
this that like there was like a jump in
time and ma co had a beard and he found
the next avatar it was like way way down
the road it could happen I think if
Korra did died then ma co probably would
seek out the next avatar the only things
we know for sure or that bright said
that the Avatar cycle would be
continuing meaning that there would be
an avatar after Korra and so on and so
on they implied that we'd see vatu in
another ten thousand years so there's
going to be X amount of avatars between
now and then I'll let you guys do the
math on that all I'm really expecting
from the finale is that they'll wrap up
all the existing plotlines answer a few
questions and give us a good enough idea
about what's going to be happening to
team avatar and everyone else afterwards
in an ambiguous enough way that it's
open to interpretation there will be
lots of crying no matter what that's
just a given but I don't think it's
going to be the downer 70s ending that
Mockingjay was you know like the big WTF
peta moment question number 10 purple
conscience says do you think the kuvira
has some kind of hidden ability like
c'mon head bending were you talking
about blood bending you nevah to had the
dark avatar energy beams and so here had
his flying levitation abilities no I
don't think the Cuvier has any special
bending abilities I think her power is
in her fandom like she has a fandom that
is supporting her it's not a cult per se
but she's like a lot of famous fascist
leaders like Mussolini Hitler
they're brainwashed people or drum them
into service so really it's her
popularity that's her special power the
only options that Cora has are to either
take away that popularity somehow or
find a way to make kuvira change your
mind about what she's doing thank you so
much everyone for so many questions
these are always a ton of fun to do and
remember episode nine is gonna post on
Friday next week just like normal if
you're watching on TV that's also the
day that they're gonna start airing book
for on nicktoons but they're starting
with episodes one and two so you will be
able to watch it on TV congratulations
to this week's giveaway winner
Christopher Musgrove you win the Amazon
gift card just message me on my channel
for details I'll be posting my
Constantine video next before walking
dead on sunday night I also might be
streaming some dragon age later tonight
for anyone that's still up I've been
wanting to play but I haven't downloaded
it yet and just a quick reminder if
you're watching on mobile or on your
tablet you can click up here for mobile
links it's the same as the links over
here but right now click here for last
week's episode and click here for
episode six thank you so much for
watching so let's all high five and I
will see you guys tonight
you